one more note about the classified
document bathroom dump that took place
at Mar-A-Lago a speaker of the house
Kevin McCarthy a republican was asked it
really doesn't look good right for Trump
to have classified documents in his
bathroom
and McCarthy actually said bathrooms
have lockable doors and actually brought
up Joe Biden this is you would think
this were a joke they're not really
going to do this are they here is Kevin
McCarthy defending documents in the
bathroom was that a good look for the
former president to have box
es up all the time a bathroom door locks
so what is he referring to this is the
story of how Joe Biden had documents in
his garage next to his Corvette
the stupidity of this is you can't just
lift the garage door from the outside
like that's not how garage doors work
but the argument that Kevin McCarthy is
making is bathrooms have lockable doors
but garages don't now it's of course
untrue it's also kind of silly because
bathrooms have lockable doors from the
inside I don't re I mean listen they
were getting really into the weeds here
but usually if you lock the bathroom
door from the outside you're what we
would call locked out many of the doors
with a little pin you can unlock it from
the outside so is that even really
secure but we're at the level the point
here is the following it's not about
lock smithery it's about Kevin McCarthy
is trying to defend the indefensible in
the same way that these Republicans have
been doing it now for a while which is
to either talk about Hillary Clinton or
in this particular case to talk about
Joe Biden it is laughable but it is not
unexpected we have a cult that is what
this is and Kevin McCarthy defending the
bathroom dump you got to see it to
believe it